avant de développer ces titres on va
commencer avec ces images
d'échauffourées la nuit dernière à
argenteuil
des images tournées par charles beaudry
dans le quartier val d'argent où des
affrontements ont éclaté entre les
forces de l'ordre et des petits groupes
d'habitants à des poubelles ont été
incendiés et des abribus saccagés la
police a fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser les attroupements cela
fait suite à la mort du jeune ça brille
dans un accident de motocross près d'une
voiture de police il aurait été percuté
il aurait percuté un poteau électrique
alors qu'il roulait sans casque a
transporté à l'hôpital il a succombé à
ses blessures hier matin sa famille et
ses proches pointe du doigt les forces
de l'ordre de leur côté on affirme que
les équipes n'avait pas d'intention de
l'interpeller ni de le contrôler et
écouter un témoin au micro de notre
reporter ils étaient poursuivis ils
étaient poursuivis eux disent qu'ils
n'étaient pas poursuivis mais c'est pas
vrai elle était poursuivie des gens
l'ont vu de joe de leurs fenêtres
voilà ils ont mieux ils ont pas me
legros gyrophare ils ont mis un petit
gyrophare avec genre qu'on voie lente
à l'intérieur la de l'intérieur ils ont
gazés tout le monde ils ont laissé
personne s'approcher et petits comme
grands ils ont de ces personnes ils ont
ils ont braqué des gens et ils ont
utilisé la bombe lacrymogène des députés
qui - et un menu des riverains qui sont
pas des plats là maintenant et non c'est
pas des gares actuelles leur ampleur
indique un jeune de 18 ans il faisait
rien de rien de rien pour vivre était
livreur d'havard voilà ils avaient péri
il avait arrêté ses études démontrent la
bonne personne jean-guy poulies travail
et n'avaient pas de casier judiciaire
rien du tout rien de tout ça et georges
mothron le maire d'argenteuil a réagi
sur twitter
il met en cause le danger que représente
parfois la pratique de la moto cette
nuit un jeune argenteuillais a perdu la
vie à moto je compatis à la douleur de
la famille et des proches
ce drame vient rappeler tristement que
la pratique inconsciente de la moto
contre laquelle nous avons lutté durant
le confinement à argenteuil comme
ailleurs met en danger des vies